[Music]
thank you you look radiant thank you
you're feeling okay thanks
just bloated
honey that's a good little
yeah but but yeah it's good it's a fun
night yes it is you got we've so been
looking forward to seeing you it's been
a minute since we've seen you out here
on these carpets i feel like yeah been a
minute since we've seen anybody it's
been a couple years i'm excited to be
here like with the whole cast
you know it's um and i'm so excited
about this movie yeah and for people to
see it um so yeah it's okay yeah and
speaking of this cast this is a stellar
cast young lady
you yourself are a stellar gal an
actress yourself not compared to
everybody in this movie but jennifer was
there anyone in particular that you
thought well i'm just having a little
star struck kind of moment here
i mean meryl streep is the actual
greatest greatest actor that's ever
lived so and then when you watch her in
person it only confirms that so i
obviously had that but i think i was
more starstruck to be around ariana
grande just because like our worlds
don't really collide like musicians and
like what she does is so different i
mean i sound similar
don't get me wrong um
better
um in the shower in the car yeah i'm
coming out with something you know i
thought you were not the baby
yeah but but it's such a different world
that it's like
you know shocking you know that girl
from live tv said we're all going to die
no girl how was it filming alongside
timothy because you said in an interview
with us that oh my gosh she thought he
was hot and good looking so you know
what was it like starting opposite yeah
i mean yeah everybody
needs to hear romantic everybody's
everybody's hot and sexy until it's five
in the morning and you're on like hour
18. but did you guys reminisce about
those headlines of yours at all though
you know we didn't bring it up probably
a good thing yeah we did not bring it up
but he's just an absolute doll
he's precious finally what are you
looking forward to most about motherhood
um god i don't know i'm just gonna have
to find out
that you're gonna be brilliant thank you
thank you very nice to see you thank you
very much
[Music]